later this month the House Energy and
Committee Commerce Committee will be
looking at at 20 different pieces of
legislation to try to fight the u.s.
growing opioid crisis the effort comes
as law enforcement struggles against the
usual suspects and the unusual ones as
well
correspondent Jonathan Serrie tells us
tonight about that from Atlanta police
federal agents taking down an alleged
drugs for sex ring in metro Atlanta the
man at the top not part of a cartel but
a former medical examiner he's a
forensic pathologist he sees dead people
so why is this person able to write
1,500 prescriptions in a two year period
90 percent of them were for pain
medicine Robert Murphy is the special
agent in charge of the Drug Enforcement
Administration's Atlanta field division
how many times he and his agents
recently arrested multiple defendants
tied to doctor Joseph Burton who's
accused of writing unnecessary opioid
prescriptions in exchange for sexual
favors the medical community constantly
talks about police and themselves
we hope that happens unfortunately it
doesn't and sometimes we have to come in
and police say DEA actions against
physicians more than quintuple from 88
cases in 2011 to 479 cases in 2016
according to research by George Mason
University's dr. Tony yang each state
keeps a prescription drug monitoring
database to help physicians and
pharmacists red flag excessive activity
but law enforcement access to these
records varies from state to state
Georgia currently requires a search
warrant or subpoena George's version of
the prescription drug monitoring
database is not as accessible to law
enforcement as other state surrounding
states a bill pending in the Georgia
Legislature would fix some of the
problems with the state's database but
does not address the issue of access for
law enforcement
although Georgia's database helped
police and prosecutors build their case
against dr. Burton they say earlier and
easier access might have helped prevent
many pills from winding up in the wrong
hands
Brett Jonathan thank you